it is starting to look a little bit more
like the holiday season here
a holiday favorite returns to the las
vegas motor speedway tonight
and we're talking about that right there
it's the glittering lights
hector mejia live this morning from the
speedway with a preview and a look at
what's different this year
hector where'd you go hector would you
disappear what's going on buddy
i did not disappear i'm right here i'm
in the middle of a neon rainforest and
look who decided to show up
it's 2020. oh no that's not 20 20.
that's the grinch
we're all happy to be here except for
the grinch
good morning everyone we are at the las
vegas motor speedway talking about
glittering lights back to the 20th year
and joining us live to talk about what's
happening tonight we have john
producer here to tell us you know you
guys have a big spectacular show plan
for tonight with fireworks that's right
hector this is our 20th anniversary
so we're kicking it off tonight if if
anybody's in line by five o'clock
they can enjoy a firework show the grand
lighting of all the light park ricardo
laguna bmx star is kind of going to do a
stunt to light it all up
and then of course santa and mrs claus
are going to come out in a ground flat
in a grand fashion and wave to everybody
and say hi
it's so exciting it's just a sign that
this year is almost over
oh my gosh yes absolutely and you know
when we last met
gosh back in september i didn't think
we'd be here but you know we've been
practicing social distancing since
before it was cool
so we've got we're old hat at this one
outdoors
inside of a vehicle away from other
people that's right
you can enjoy this entire experience
from the safety warmth and comfort of
your car
you know for parents with little kids
you don't have strollers to deal with
you don't have to deal
you know with worrying about mass you
can all stay in your car and if you
purchase your tickets online and even
your concessions online
it's all contactless you were telling me
earlier today is i believe you said
world
kindness day today exactly is that today
is world kindness day so
you know when you're out spread some
kindness around and we're gonna do the
same today
compliments of aaron taylor everybody
that comes is going to get a free
uh ticket to pass it along to someone
else we need kindness
especially today on friday the 13th
2020.
yeah i'm hoping world kindness day will
actually counteract the
friday the 13th 1 john so tell us about
the lights 5 million lights you guys
spent several weeks putting
everything together yeah this actually
started when it was still 100 degrees
out here in vegas oh my
it's uh we started black light in
october we had a crew of about 40 people
come out here almost every day seven
days a week uh
creating this uh like display we have
over 700 displays
uh as you said this is the first year
we've had five million lights
and uh just a ton of new activation and
areas for people to enjoy all right john
thank you very much so we have two and a
half miles to go through we've been
walking around all morning and we have a
little bit more to show you
so we'll be back in half an hour to show
you another part of glittering lights
as they glitter here at the speedway for
now reporting live hector mejia back to
you guys
merry christmas happy holidays no but
full
full props by the way to the grinch
behind you
for staying in character all morning
long he is clearly
in full grinchified mode i think he just
needs uh some coffee i think that's all
he needs well
and i'd make a lot of us a grinch thank
you hector thank you mr grinch